let's go back to the cowboys yeah
because they were 3-0
and we had some video of jerry jones in
the locker room and i i saw a tweet from
calvin watkins of the dallas morning
news that jerry jones was was shaken
yesterday it was his 77th birthday this
cowboys team was supposed to be special
they had everything lined up they paid
ezekiel elliot to get him into the fold
we remember talking after three weeks do
they have any weaknesses other than
coaching no but you know the coaching is
now starting to rear its ugly head i
think they're relying too much on the
talent of the team there isn't enough
scheming there's enough game planning
there's enough creativity and now we
have to wonder jason garrett who's only
under contract through this year yeah
is he in a situation where a disastrous
loss to the eagles for example on sunday
night football could that be the thing
that causes jerry jones to roll out of
bed the next day and say i got to make a
change i don't think so i you know again
now where they're in trouble if they
lose this weekend is i think they're
like forget the wild card no that's
gonna happen but they're still very much
in the race to win the nfc east and i
think you stay the course 100 percent
you know but here's the thing yeah if
they lose to the eagles at home right
they have to play in philadelphia later
this year yeah i know you get swept yeah
you've got to make up three games right
elsewhere i know and that's not going to
be easy no it's not easy but they they
went into philadelphia last year on
sunday night football and beat them
right we can't forget about that you
know they're they are kind of one of
those teams when you think they're not
gonna their backs are against the wall
they somehow you know pull through it
they have incredible talent you know you
can live with the saints loss a few
weeks ago okay the packers lost last
week even though it's not easy to live
with hey mistakes happen dak prescott
interceptions early they get behind not
a good look certainly um but then you
know this game yesterday i think is
where the concern level rises a little
bit because we know they are far
superior than the new york jets and the
new york jets have been unable to really
do anything i think i was just surprised
that the offense couldn't punch in the
ball for touchdowns having to settle for
field goals
not sustaining drives or finding big
plays in the run game or the pass game
really throughout the day and then the
defense letting up some of the big plays
you know early on i think that was
another thing i just did not expect i
thought the cowboys would kind of
overwhelm that jets offense in general
and yeah they would win a game by 10 or
14 points something like that but the
jets had other plans and they had a good
game plan off the bye week and sammy
darnold gave no lift yeah it was last
year they were three and five going into
a sunday night game at the eagles and
and at the time right there was a
thought that if they got embarrassed it
could be that's it for for jason garrett
and and that vibe has begun to creep
back in even though they're only three
and three the bar was so much higher
this year and you get off to that 3-0
start last year they started one and two
that creates expectations that begins to
develop the sense that it's going to be
a special season and they've seen the
special season come crashing down and
like you said now it it i think they're
already at the point where based upon
how this team has played the past few
weeks it's nfc east championship or
you're not going to the playoffs and uh
look what they are able to do by way of
holding serve at home on sunday night
against the eagle is going to go a long
way toward determining whether they win
that division and i don't like god we've
been so bad at picking these sunday
night games this year i i think i'm
gonna i think i'm going to make my
decision and then literally do the
opposite yeah yeah i know it's uh you
know you yeah conventional wisdom would
would make you think oh dallas is at
home you know backs against the wall
they should be able to win this game the
problem is you know the eagles are
talented too now they're beat up that's
their biggest issue but the eagles are
certainly not going to be intimidated by
the dallas cowboys the eagles you know
got a lot of big people up front on both
sides of the ball they're not going to
lose that match up in any you know bad
way or anything like that you know the
the thing i look at you know more than
anything i'm a little disappointed
ezekiel who's been good i'm not trying
to say he's not good i just think he's
doesn't look quite as explosive to me so
that's concerning to me um you know the
the pass offense i think has been very
good it's encouraging it's as good as
we've seen you know since tony romo and
his prime the defense i do have like my
concerns there i know there's talent
demarcus lawrence hasn't been as good um
but the big thing there and going into
the coaching thing is i do think their
defense has to be a little bit more game
plan specific you know they are one of
those teams and i know you've heard me
say this lots and lots that they just go
out there you know what the cowboys are
gonna play and do they don't like really
do anything special on a week-to-week
basis they just go this is what we do
we're really talented our power our
speed is just going to overwhelm you
we're going to hustle we're going to
tackle and do all that okay great but
you know this is the nfl even when you
are a really talented team like the
dallas cowboys you're not like so much
more greatly talented than maybe one of
the worst teams in football in the new
york jets to where you can just roll out
there and go we're just gonna be us and
beat them no i mean the new england
patriots game plan then did a lot of
different stuff when they played the new
york jets they didn't just go we're in
new england and we're home and we're
gonna beat them no they treated it like
damn they got some good things and you
know you hear bill belichick the jets
are really good in all three areas a
really good overall team and they they
never fall into that trap they always go
we gotta find ways to help our players
and i don't know we see that especially
in the cowboys d yeah it's just we're a
supremely talented team and we're just
going to show up and we're going to do
what we do and right and i think they
need to have more creativity and it
makes me wonder whether or not if they
continue to lose these games you know
jason garrett's status beyond this
season is seriously in doubt right now
but whether or not at some point jerry
jones would decide to give chris richard
an opportunity to be the interim coach
just to audition once you know that's
the thing once you know you're making
the change
that's when you want to give somebody
else a chance to show what they can do
can they win some games under pressure
because that's what did with jason
garrett and wade phillips nine years ago
i get it wade phillips was was gone and
jason garrett got a chance to prove that
that he's the guy and and i can't help
but wonder whether or not chris richard
is going to be the new jason garrett but
it's something to keep an eye on
especially as these losses continue to
pile up
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports